It's about time we want a name.
Haha,
it's hard to call people from the subspace without a name.
I'm not even sure about the name that the master gave me.
Sakainege Anyway, my name is overflowing with me 2
Pooh
good good
a ridge baku baku
good
[music]
none is the soil, so Rakuhodo Okay
, I think it's a friend group
Yeah, the name of the bravest female star I know  Did you have a female samurai that
you
gave
me?
Of course there is 826 It's not important, but I'm happy if the master really wants to give it to me
No, but I'm the next one, right?
If there is a law, can you tell me?
In
my country of birth, I added the character that represents zero to the character that I'm good at, the water attribute
.
When I convene, I want to dye it in color